oh this is stunning hello and welcome to
our guide to Need for Speed payback
brought to you by ei I am Dan MA and I
am joined by my partner in crime
Jonnie hey did a good man write today we
are going to be tackling street races
the street leagues
these are the races that you'll
participate in through our payback
storyline where you as a variety of
characters will take part in a series of
street races to climb your way into the
street racing ranks we're very playing
as Tyler and Mac who both have different
disciplines Tyler being master of the
road race and Mac being an off-roader so
between myself and Yanni we're gonna try
and defeat all comers and climb the
ranks so edge frontier chances I'm
excited and I think we'll do well we're
going to smash it
so this is the first Street League
graveyard shift this is a race Sentret
League so this is this is tile
especially either six racers you're in
fifth and it's two point seven miles
you know what this is not - hello not
too shabby
my Road us to keep ahead can't beat that
night good things are stack up isn't it
keep that nitro so just if you just
misjudge a corner and they get the edge
on you can just turbo passed in again
Latrice is the one I think that we need
to look up ya know stay on the road
concentrate sorry
come on does give me the controller know
about this
look the triest gone Palakkad you pull
this on
who's left forges where is he cuz I'm no
you didn't win the race no second place
okay we're getting money those third
okay we're still getting rewarded my
face so I can't complain
don't work playing night now this is the
other Street League this is the one that
the Mac take spine because these are all
the off-road focus races so we are in a
nice suit of defender sorry but I'm
taking this I burn what I like is that
the the side bets do seem to suit the
style of race so with off-road races
because you're in a sturdy vehicle is
about finding stuff on the roads either
you can smash it takes you off the ball
though it takes you off the ball trying
to steer steer off track just to knock
over a bollard or two it can be a
struggle because we are now eight point
shy the recommended requirement for this
race so we've got a reliance of raw
talent which is fading at that point
however you are hitting some objects I
mean about eight objects that hits a
very short race though I think the one
advantage even though some of these are
the cars are off road is that you are in
a much heftier vehicle so if you do want
to get a little bit physical to get the
edge be de the be a bit dirty all right
let's get hippie out you've smashed into
first place fantastic you're just under
a mile now I'm just throwing up my
nitrous gonna hit they've been and go
for it
[Music]
so how you enjoying the sort of off-road
racing versus racing on the race on the
streets I love your fruits so much fun
watch out for this rock grazed it 500
yards remaining but no one likes that
one comes I'm screwed oh boy that was a
car oh yes
new record set as well fantastic
I like the side bit but we're not
worried about that that's good but the
new reckless they gave us some money so
that's just a little taster of the
Street League action in Need for Speed
payback
yeah how did you enjoy that loved it I
really like the off-road in I like the
fact you can jump over items hit things
and it doesn't affect the drive
yeah it just means and all the things
that geared towards just breaking stuff
basically and smashing up the opposition
what I enjoy that's what we like and
we'll be back with more Need for Speed
payback action in future videos and next
up we're going to be taking a look at
some of the games moments
[Music]